in our other videos
and as always there'll be links below if
you want to check those out
we showed you how to initialize and
fine-tune a transformer model in
tensorflow
so the question now is what can we do
with a model after we train it
the obvious thing to try is to use it to
get predictions for new data
so let's see how to do that again if
you're familiar with keras the good news
is that because these are just standard
keras models
we can use the standard keras predict
method as shown here
you simply pass in tokenized text to
this method
like you'd get from a tokenizer and you
get your results
our models can output several different
things depending on the options you set
but most of the time the thing you want
is the output logits
if you haven't come across them before
logits sometimes pronounced
logits because no one's sure are the
outputs of the last layer of the network
because before a soft max has been
applied so if you want to turn the
logits into the model's probability
outputs
you just apply a soft max like so
what if we want but what if we want to
turn those probabilities into class
predictions
again it's very straightforward we just
pick the biggest probability for each
output and you can get that immediately
with the arg max function
argmax will return the index of the
largest probability in each row
which means that we'll get a vector of
integers
so zero if the largest probability was
in the zeroth position one in the first
position and so on
so these are our class predictions
indicating class 0
class 1 and so on in fact if class
predictions are all you want
you can skip the softmax step entirely
because the largest logit will always be
the largest probability as well
so if probabilities and class
predictions are all you want
then you've seen everything you need at
this point but if you're interested in
benchmarking your model or using it for
research
you might want to delve deeper into the
results you get and one way to do that
is to compute some metrics for the
model's predictions
if you're following along with our data
sets and fine-tuning videos
we got our data from the mrpc data set
which is part of the blue benchmark
each of the blue datasets as well as
many other data sets
in our datasets lighthub has some
predefined metrics
and we can read that we can load them
easily with the dataset's
loadmetric function for the m or pc
dataset
the built-in metrics are accuracy which
just measures the percentage of the time
the model's prediction was correct
and the f1 score which is a slightly
more complex measure that measures how
well the model
trades off precision and recall
to compute those metrics to benchmark
our model we just pass them the model's
predictions
and the ground truth labels and we get
our results in a straightforward dip
python dict
if you're familiar with keras though you
might notice that this is a slightly
weird way to compute metrics because
we're only computing metrics at the very
end of training
but in keras you have this built-in
ability to compete compute a wide range
of metrics on the fly while you're
training
which gives you a very useful insight
into how training is going
so if you want to use built-in metrics
it's very straightforward
and you use the standard keras approach
again you just pass a metric
argument to the compile method as with
things like loss and optimizer
you can specify the metrics you want by
string or you can import the actual
metric objects and pass specific
arguments to them but note that unlike
loss and accuracy
you have to supply metrics as a list
even if there's only one metric you want
once a model has been compiled with a
metric it will report that metric for
training
validation and predictions
assuming there are labels passed to the
predictions you can even write your own
metric classes
although this is a bit beyond the scope
of this course i'll link to the relevant
tf docs below because it can be very
handy if you want a metric that isn't
supported by default in keras
such as the f1 score